heute gibt's ein saftiges Hähnchen aus
der Pfanne mit
kartoffelstamm ah komm ne mal noch ein
bissel mehr keine Soße keine Soße okay
meine Kinder sind Hal so keine
soßenkinder hab es einfach immer
gegessen war so
gut hallo herzlich willkommen in sallyys
Welt die Mädels und ich haben Hunger
deswegen gibt jetzt ein richtig leckeres
Gericht mit wenigen Zutaten was ihr zu
Hause perfekt vorbereiten könnt ich habe
jetzt hier schon mal melig kochende
Kartoffel nämlich ein Kil geschältes
Gewicht hab sie auch schon halbiert und
die werden jetzt bei mir im Dampfgarer
zubereitet da behalten sie nämlich den
Geschmack komplett es verwässert nichts
ihr könnt sie aber natürlich auch wenn
ihr keine Dampfgarer zu Hause habt im
Topf einfach mit Wasser kochen bis sie
gar sind ich zeige euch das jetzt mal
hier hinten ich habe den boschofen da
habt ihr dämpfen plus das gart quasi
über 100° bis 120° das ganze geht
schneller ist vitaminschonender und hier
gebe ich jetzt einfach die Kartoffeln
rein perfekt
und dann kann das Ganze einmal dämpfen
und in der Zeit kann ich schon mal das
Hähnchen machen fürs Hähnchen verwende
ich etwas Olivenöl ich habe mein
Knoblauch Olivenöl ihr könnt aber auch
Knoblauch Zeh dazu nehmen eine Zwiebel
400 g Champignons hier habe ich etwas
Stärke dann Tymian Salz und Pfeffer hier
habe ich eine ausmahl an Hähnchen und
zwar acht unterkeulen zwei Hühnerbrüste
und 500 g Hühnerbrühe ich nehme immer
gern die induktionsmatte auf dem
Induktionskochfeld denn da kann der
Bräter dann nicht verrut oder auch der
Kochtopf und das ganze geht aber nur auf
Induktion das ist gut zu wissen lässt
trotzdem natürlich die Hitze durch und
das ganze verrutscht nicht und euer Herz
kratzt nicht ich ma das jetzt einfach
hier im Samira
Bräter da passt nämlich super rein und
ihr könnt auch hier schon direkt den
Bräter erwärmen auf mittelhoher Hitze
ich ne das Knoblauchöl immer gut
schütteln eine richtig schöne neue
Rezeptur
Knoblauch spar ich mir direkt das
Knoblauch schälen und bis es jetzt hier
warm ist kann ich schon mal die Zwiebel
fein hacken und die champingungs einfach
in Scheiben
schneiden jetzt ist es Fett wararm und
ich kann das Hähnchen von allen Seiten
einfach schön anbraten und dann nehme
ich es noch mal kurz raus dient jetzt
einfach dazu dass ich so ein bisschen
rüstaromen
[Musik]
bekomme die Hähnchenbrust Brade ich
jetzt auch ein bisschen an die habe ich
kurz so ein bisschen klein gehackt und
große Stücke
gehabt wie viel Sauerei macht es bitte
ich also ja kann man schon sagen so
Fleisch anbraten ist nett so meins
spritzt drum es riecht deswegen
bevorzuge ich scharfskäse aus dem Ofen
und Fleisch grille ich lieber draußen
ganz einfach aber was tut man nicht
alles für seine Kinder okay ich hab
Fleisch rausgenommen dann kommen jetzt
die Zwiebel in die
Pfanne ich habe noch genug Fett drin
einfach schön
anbraten nach einer Minute kommen die
Champignons dazu die braten wir jetzt
auch schön scharf an das gibt alles
Geschmack Ella magst du lieber die
Hähnchen Stücke mit Knochen oder die
ohne
ohne ge ich die Stärke dazu zum
binden einfach mit der Brühe schön
ablöschen dann schön rühren jetzt könnt
ihr mit Salz Pfeffer und Thymian
abschmecken und das Ganze kurz köcheln
lassen und dann lege ich einfach das
Hähnchen wieder zurück mach den Deckel
drauf und es darf so ungefähr 25 Minuten
lang bei niedriger Stufe einfach
durchziehen und köcheln damit das
Hähnchen gar wird die Kartoffeln sind
jetzt perfekt gar die gebe ich jetzt
hier einfach in einen Topf wir können
natürlich auch einfach eine große Schale
nehmen beim Topf habe ich jetzt halt den
Vorteil ist auch ein gusseisentopf ich
habe den kurz mit in den Dampfgarer
gestellt dass der warm ist dann bleibt
mein Kartoffelstampf nämlich auch schön
warm jetzt könnt ihr hier euren
Kartoffelstampf mit Butter und Milch
verfeinern etwas SalzPfeffer und
Muskatnuss dazu reiben ihr könnt aber
auch hier ganz gerne noch mal
knoblaucholivenöl dazu geben das mache
ich auch gleich so ein schönen
ordentlichen Schluck und dann einfach
mit dem wacker schön
zerkleinern die Butter gibt halt auch
einen richtig einzigartigen Geschmack
dann gebe ich noch ein bisschen mil dazu
müsst ihr aber auch nicht wenn ihr es
nicht so cremig haben wollt sondern
kartoffeliger könnt das auch so lassen
aber ich finde es passt immer ganz gut
mach die ruhig vorher ein bisschen warm
dann kühlt das ganze nicht so ab und
jetzt nur noch mit Salz Pfeffer und
Muskat
abschmecken jetzt ist das gerecht
fertig ja Muffin ist leider nicht für
dich darf leider nur die Ella probieren
also wir machen ein bisschen
Kartoffelpüree und dann
Hähnchen und Soße ohne Champignons
willst du ne keine Soße keine Soße keine
Soße keine Soße okay meine Kinder sind
halt so keine soßenkinder dann bekommst
du Ella das tomatensen tomatensoßen
stimmt dann kriegst du das und ich riete
jetzt einfach noch eine Teller an darf
ich so ein bisschen Soße an Rand und bei
dir kurz
mitprobieren ja komm
so
m ist gut oder ma jetzt gleichin Bereich
okay ist mein Bereich mein Bereich ist
der mit Soße und deiner ist ohne Soße
ich mach bei mir gleich noch ein
bisschen peterselie oben drauf Samira
ist bestimmt auch mit Soße das Rezept
gibt's für euch zum Nachkochen in meiner
App oder auch sblog.de ganz genau und
was ist dein Urteil schmeckt ja du magst
nur die so Soße nicht also dust ohne
Soße aber das Fleisch ist du Gott ich h
auch mal richtig Lust auf Knödel ich
möchte einfach gerne Knödel Essen bitte
schreibt mir in die Kommentare dass ihr
Knödel sehen wollt dann ma ich gerne
Knödel da läuft mir schon das Wasser im
zusammen also macht's gut bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss und am Sonntag
mama was Hübsches leckeres
süßes herziges ich habe ich habe auch
Hunger ich schnappe mir meinen Teller
und komm zu
dir